eine scheiß mutter der in sich ruht die
sein leben antreibt
wut und unendliche liebe zur musik musik
hat ihm im wahrsten sinne das leben
gerettet und der klavierhocker ist der
einzige platz auf der welt wo er sich
wirklich geerdet fühlt
musik ist wie eine wundertüte keine
nebenwirkungen ist euer du musst nicht
kriminell werden und du warst nicht am
morgen verkatert neben drei wildfremden
drauf und fragst dich wie zum teufel du
da hingekommen ist
musik hilft immer und lässt dich niemals
im stich
das klingt nach einer menge
lebenserfahrung und tatsächlich was
dieser plan es zu überwinden hatte ist
schwer erträglich
ein everest von einem trauma so nennt er
es aufgewachsen in einem wohlhabenden
viertel in london schicken ihn die
eltern in einer privatschule dort
missbraucht ein sportlehrer sein
vertrauen
er vergewaltigt den siebenjährigen james
immer und immer wieder
jahrelang
das verbrechen zerstört den lebendigen
jungen in ihm in dieser tragische zeit
fällt ein erlebnis das ihn aufrüttelt
die sichere ahnung musik kann heilen
er entdeckt die musik von bach beginnt
klavier zu spielen
ich war sieben als ich dieses stück wird
und was sofort verzaubert
es war das was therapeuten meinen wenn
sie sagen du musst einen sicheren ort
finden
das war diese musik eine ganz neue welt
ging auf dieser sichere ort heißt chacon
das stück musik das bach nach dem tod
seiner frau schrieb eine musikalische
kathedrale
das änderte alles für mich in dem moment
wusste ich ich werde eine lebenslange
beziehung zur musik haben und ich will
pianistin ungeheuer talentiert war er
doch lange zeit nicht in der lage seinen
weg als musiker zu gehen
das trauma des missbrauches macht ihm zu
schaffen
mit 18 hatte auf klavier zu spielen will
nichts als ein normales leben führen
mit hausfrau karriere und kind
doch die narben brechen auf sein leben
wird über zwei jahrzehnte zum
horror-trip drogenexzesse psychiatrie
suizidversuche wie viele opfer von
kindsmissbrauch leidet er an einer
mixtur aus selbsthass und selbstmitleid
bis die kraft der musik erneut in sein
leben tritt
mein freund schmuggelte einen winzigen
ipod in die psychiatrie
ich dachte ich weiß schon alles über
bachs klavierstücke
aber dann hätte ich das und das war
wieder so ein moment wie damit als kein
bieter chacon wie kann jemand so etwas
erschaffen
und wenn das möglich ist dann ist die
welt nicht einfach nur ein furchtbarer
ort mit schrecklichen menschen
es muss etwas größeres und besseres
geben
er weiß nun er will konzertpianist
werden nimmt intensiv unterricht und
stellt sich dem kampf vor rückschlägen
schützt ihn das nicht neue abstürze
folgen
selbstverstümmelung mit rasierklingen
gehört lange zum alltag
dennoch er hat es geschafft
james rhodes hat inzwischen fünf alben
eingespielt gibt konzerte die anders
sind immer spricht er zu seinem publikum
über die stücke die ihn so viel bedeuten
und über das nischendasein von
klassischer musik
was mich irritiert ist wie sehr die
klassische musik heute vom leben
abgetrennt ist
irgendwie hat man sie beiseite geschoben
in eine ecke wie einen etwas seltsamen
onkel auf dem familienfest mit dem die
kinder besser nicht alleine sind
sein leben ist heute leichter doch die
gefahr des absturzes bleibt erstaunlich
offen schreibt james rhodes nun darüber
der klang der wut liebevoll und
enthusiastisch wo er ein universum
zwischen 88 tasten erschließt und rotzig
wo er sich denn müll des lebens von der
seele schreibt ich bin nicht so naiv zu
sagen wenn es dir nicht gut geht für die
musik an und sofort ist alles gut
natürlich nicht denn es war nicht nur
das
es waren freunde und irgendwann meine
frau es waren pillen und ärzte und
kliniken aber die eine sache die immer
da durch die übelsten zeiten hindurch
das war die musik